within minutes of yesterday's
announcement that new york attorney
general letitia james is suing trump and
his family for 250 million dollars in
seeking to bar his organization from
doing business in new york over multiple
instances of alleged fraud donald trump
took to his failed social media platform
truth social also known as truth central
to trump
and
viciously attacked leticia james
not defending himself on the merits but
just attacking letitia james let's take
a look at a few of these posts donald
trump starting with quote
another witch hunt by a racist attorney
general leticia james who failed in her
run for governor getting almost zero
support from the public and now is doing
poorly against law and order attorney
general candidate highly respected
michael henry
i never thought this case would be
brought until i saw her really bad poll
numbers implying it's all political she
is a fraud
who campaigned on a get trump platform
despite the fact that the city is one of
the crime and murder disasters of the
world under her watch
trump continuing attorney general
leticia peek-a-boo james i don't have no
clue what peek-a-boo is all about a
total crime-fighting disaster in new
york is spending all of her time
fighting for very powerful and
well-represented banks and insurance
companies who were fully paid
made a lot of money and never had a
complaint about me instead of fighting
murder and violent crime which is
killing new york state she is a failed
attorney general whose lack of talent in
the fight against crime is causing
record numbers of people and companies
to flee new york bye-bye
and then lastly trump continuing his
attack
not defending himself on the charges but
just attacking the messenger
the new york times her peek-a-boo james
case against him could be difficult to
prove property valuations are often
subjective and the financial statements
include a very strong disclaimer
thank you
so this is going to be a fight but it is
problem after problem for donald trump
and i'll be i'll be perfectly frank with
you
i don't know whether trump plans to run
for president in 24.
i don't know whether trump believes that
running for president will somehow
insulate him from the repercussions of
all of these legal problems the people
doing the prosecution say it will not
but it remains to be seen
but it is increasingly looking like it's
going to be really difficult
to run for president at the same time
that there are so many legal problems
that you were facing we'll see what
ultimately happens and all of these
clips that i played for you are
available on our instagram which you can
find by searching instagram for david
pakman show
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below